what do you think about the fact that  the polls say that 7 and 10 black  Americans now expect Obama to win which  is a big difference from the way this  campaign started when he first ran for  president he actually did not have that  kind of support not nearly in the polls  and the reason we were told was that  blacks did not want to be disappointed  now they think he can win if he doesn't  win what's going to happen if Obama  doesn't win what's going to happen  well that Wednesday after election day  don't if any activity you have in your  life that involves black people it's not  gonna get done  you know we got in the airport no one's  gonna get your bag